the man who ran former president trump's
inaugural committee
has now been arrested on charges of
acting as an agent of foreign government
tom barrack a longtime friend and
adviser to mr trump is also charged with
obstruction of justice
and making false statements to federal
agents nancy cordes has more on this
story
74-year-old tom barrack listened in
court as
prosecutors listed off the charges
conspiracy to act as an
agent of a foreign government
obstruction of justice
and making false statements to the fbi
donald trump is one of my closest
friends for 40 years
barrack allegedly used that friendship
to advance the interests of the united
arab emirates an
oil-rich middle eastern country
according to the indictment barrick
provided the uae with
information about meetings that occurred
at the white house
and he pushed the white house to make
the president's speeches
more favorable to the uae we'll work
with our gulf allies
to develop a positive energy
relationship
that speech in 2016 won barrack praised
from his main
uae contact who emailed him to say
amazing congrats on the great job today
it's not about power it's about cash and
a lot of it
harry littman is a former u.s attorney
he says
barrick never registered as a foreign
agent even as his company raked in
millions from the uae
what's really going on here is there was
influence by a foreign government
on the president and the country just
didn't
know about it former president trump
thought so highly of barrick he tapped
him to run the inauguration in 2016.
now barrick joins a long list of former
trump associates who were
indicted after working with or for him
barracks lawyers say he is not guilty
and that he's been cooperating with
investigators from the beginning but
prosecutors argue that the wealthy
california investor
is a flight risk so he'll be held in
jail
until a bail hearing next week vlad all
right nancy thank you very much